all right everybody its tipsy elves
that's right tipsy elves everyone needs
an ugly Christmas sweater this time of
year if you want bragging rights for the
most talked-about sweater at your
Christmas party listen up did you see
these guys on Shark Tank a couple weeks
ago with their latest update everyone is
talking about tipsy elves not in my
world
and once they're outrageous Christmas
sweaters I'm sure they are and the
Christmas sweater circles I'm sure this
this conversation is all afire anyways
talk about your tipsy elves sweater and
other products you saw on the website
well I didn't see any trust me when I
tell you that these tipsy elves
Christmas sweaters are like nothing
you've ever seen before they are not for
the faint of heart
nobody's worn these ugly sweaters before
before you so you don't have to worry
about finding your size and you have a
ton of styles to choose from while
you're shopping for an ugly sweater
check out the other holiday and
collegiate attire for yourself or as a
gift like an adult onesie so what kind
of perverts are running this thing it
sounds like shut up bill just read it
alright right now my listeners get 20%
off tipsy elves calm or anything they
order on their site go do this now so
they have the best selection to choose
from and have it in time for your ugly
Christmas sweater party go to tipsy
elves calm and use the promo code BRR
who the hell was an adult onesie that's
like those [ __ ] people that still act
like babies you know what I mean they
have a giant adult crib remember that on
Opie and Anthony it was [ __ ]
infuriating anyways Merry Christmas
everybody oh it's my favorite here we go
Debbie everybody in club Debbie at tear
my daddy bought me a ranch don't you
hate when wine looks like a 10 but it
winds up looking like it's tasting like
a 6 or even worse when you walk into the
store to pick out your wine you could
easily be fooled into a situation like
this well now there's this new wine club
club Debbie we knew about Isis before
they did they've changed everything no
more being fooled by
that pretend to be hotter or tastier
than they actually are it's easy just go
to club W Club W W calm and answer six
simple questions their algorithm creates
a pallet profile just for you then they
send wine directly to your dock to your
door perfectly customized to match your
taste club Debbie you fool me once don't
worry you're not before me cam is
leading the grape to glass wine
revolution they work directly with the
vineyards to cut out the middlemen which
saved you money so when you go to Club W
smarter than [ __ ] you get premium wine
customized to your tastes at a third of
what you would pay at the store they
even have a no risk hundred-percent
guarantee that you're gonna love what
they send you and right now when you go
to Club Debbie and don't count the votes
is offering my listeners 50% off your
first order when you go to Club Debbie
Saddam's gonna be toast club w.com / / -
stop wasting time and money messing
around at retail stores and start
drinking wine now you know you're gonna
love just go to club Debbie
Jim's coming club w.com / bird to get
50% off your first order that's club
Debbie comm / bar I'll just do like a
quick little intro yes oh man alright
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast that I just check it in on you
checking in on your we care as mentioned
I was going to have a special guest one
of my favorite comedians of all time and
I still think brutally brutally [ __ ]
underrated mr. P Corey le I've known him
since when I moved to New York he's got
a new special let me get all this [ __ ]
out of the way he's got a new special
all that streaming on showtime kids God
knows you guys like the streaming stuff
alright it's called let me tell you just
came out to rave reviews one of my
favorite comics and people of all time
Mr P Corey Alec Billy Billy I don't even
I don't even know how to take that intro
and
I hug you across the table I gotta put
that in a bar like a studio audience
[ __ ] brutally brutally underrated
it's as if it is my wife is saying the
words in the kitchen I say that oh dude
I swear I mean come on two weeks before
I did the special before it came out I
was I was on a boat I was on a cruise
who's on a cruise like two weeks before
this special comes out why well no you
already know you already you already
taped it you were already taped yeah
yeah yeah balls man I'd be free I was
too I think you're saying two weeks
before you tape the [ __ ] thing you
were on a cruise like I got this No Bud
Light that you imagine no I mean oh no I
quit forming on a cruise I mean at some
point I would do a joke and I literally
just say and they sit at the bar and put
bread in my gr and say man what are you
I didn't have to get it they don't even
get it right anyway I appreciate it dude
what uh let me ask you this - what when
you go to do a special like when do you
feel like your hours ready the ever I
don't know man I don't know it's as
crazy the fight it's the first one I did
I felt a little more like it was ready
like it was like it was like you know
because I never did the first one you're
always ready cuz you've been doing it
for [ __ ] ever wait yeah somebody give
you a shot and I never did a half hour
of any kind so it was really I had the
whole gamut everything I ever written up
until that point everything half hour
for Comedy Central no no oh well at the
time by the time he came point my
manager goes I think we can get you a
half hour I go I think I can I got an
hour yeah so I laid it down at a club
and sent it to them and they right away
gave me the hour and I felt really great
after that and then this second one was
a bit more of a grind like really
grinding it out again you're one of the
guys like I watch how you're doing it
like you know and Louie - and I'm like
how what are these guys sleeping at
night and elves are writing this [ __ ]
putting about a foot in their bed okay
keep up so but by the end you know III
really felt it was there but I gotta
tell you man if I had to wait like six
more months to take that special I
probably would have forgotten what was
funny about some of those jokes
that's what think so but you get yeah I
always have to get it right to the point
where you like dude I'm so [ __ ] sick
of doing this and then it's like okay I
got to burn this thing
yeah and then move on so I try to do
them like just about every other year or
so so this year coming up is the year
where maybe towards the end of year I'm
gonna do it I was just talking to my guy
about it and you know he's going to you
ready you're ready I'm like nah I don't
think I got a make sure there's a few
things I want to push a little bit
further cuz cuz you're competing against
your last one so it has to be at least
that level which you never want it to be
because then it's more of the same from
Bilbo right which is which is worse than
somebody saying you suck you know and
everybody Internet such kuntum he's
gonna [ __ ] it no but I mean you're
working at the top level so I'll give
you back in 340 every years three forty
year after year really that bad but I
gotta say the last special all your
stuff is just unreal but when you did
the bit where you're playing catch with
all that one dude are you kidding me I
mean that's like I could see a kid
watching that I'm sorry that's that's
like on the level of the greatest of
great all right I'm sorry I'm sitting
there watching that but the difference
between when you're at two though is you
are the only one who decides right like
for me when I I knew I wanted to do it
with Showtime I didn't want to go back
to these places when they air at once
and it's done yeah you can't do that now
right so I got to the point where I sent
it to them they go we're not saying no
but we're not saying yes but they were
nice enough to work with me right so I
tweet some stuff because I had some
stuff that was just current events and
I'm not a current event guy so I I I
worked on another six months sent it
back in and then the guys at Showtime
said alright come to LA we want to see
it once live and we'll make our dishes
and decision basically at the end of
that night so I'm like 10 minutes people
that they're just giving away half hours
to the fact that you got to jump through
all these extra hoops do they fly you of
course no no not that I stated the
Safari and burn bag
as you know I got 10 minutes left and
the sets going great you know I mean
it's the Icehouse - we call you that
fast - you know but you're like 10
minutes left you like nobody drop a
glass come on man you know what great I
know what great and finally I got it and
I really you know and looking back on it
I'm like man I'm glad these guys made me
wait six months because it's better than
it was six months ago
definitely and if I could decide when I
could do my own specials my next one
would be coming out next Wednesday oh
really well not really but you you know
you you sometimes you think something's
great and then like a year lady like I
can't believe I thought that was great
now it's great right see that's what
that's my paranoia is like you want to
do in that perfect thing where you're
sick of the [ __ ] thing
and you can't squeeze anything we can't
bring anything up a little bit better
you taped it right at the perfect time
but what's [ __ ] up dude is we were
just when you came in here for people
listening here is I don't know we just
you get to a certain age in just years
even though you're counting with
birthdays they everything just feels
like it was five years ago and you were
talking about we played this this touch
football game all these comics in
Central Park yeah and we knew that was
like 20 years ago I thought was like
early 2000s and I was thinking I was at
Bobby Kelly and we were trying to figure
out what we saw so it was we were so
sore the next day I was like yeah dude
come on man with 30 he goes dude don't
[ __ ] say that I'm not 30 cuz he was
like the FK he's like two three years
younger than me but I was 29 gonna be 30
so that means that it was sometime in
1997 it's almost 2016 yeah was [ __ ]
20 years ago and I remember [ __ ]
Bobby getting so I've told this story on
the old Opie and Anthony show Bobby got
so [ __ ] mad during that game I was
blocking him or something and like he
just I see I saw is like his nostrils
were flaring I got all competitive right
yeah and he was he was gonna come in I
think I had a couple of catches and he
didn't have any yet he's so funny so he
gets all competitors [ __ ] nostrils of
flarin and he comes flying at me right
and like he just took the wrong step I
just sort of pushed him down to the
ground and it was just sort of
effortless because he kind of [ __ ] I
remember that he started falling first
so I just sort of guided him to the
ground it was like when Don Zimmer ran
it [ __ ] Pedro he just sort of guy
yeah
he got so mad he [ __ ] grabbed two
handfuls of grass ripped him out of the
ground and then just both hands [ __ ]
threw manaman at me as hard as he could
and I was like four feet away from so
for like two feet the grass goes like
ninety million out miles an hour and
then it was grass and they're like a
foot later just went like dropped
between the two of us and I was looking
at like what the [ __ ] I remember the one
of the one of those kids you know we
didn't know everybody was some Puerto
Rican kid there he just looks at Bobby
he goes yo he buggy one of the maddest I
ever saw him
but do we used to [ __ ] play
rollerblade hockey this is all nineties
[ __ ] I remember we stood like every six
games me and him would almost get into a
fistfight we never quite got to that
level but uh but dude that was way back
in the dam we used to work I remember
the Boston comedy club G Hamlet what are
you kidding me of course I mean that was
lazy I don't think I don't I always
wanted a foots because we were new to
doing stand-up yeah yeah that and we
didn't know what we were doing that that
room was so like just like just the
death that you could die in in that
[ __ ] building or if it really was as
difficult moves [ __ ] insane when I
first came down like 94 like people
selling drugs right outside the front of
it he walked in it was an absolute
[ __ ]
Barry Katz owned it put like [ __ ]
three cents into the thing had that old
[ __ ] up place yeah of course behind
you on stage in like the piece of wood
could come out and I just remembered
when you went in there it was like I
don't if it was any other room I would
have been like you know what [ __ ] this
but after I took a pound a bit like this
place this place is [ __ ] up but but
there was something about it because of
the comics that were working the eyes
are work and they were insane yeah you
wanted to be able to have a good set in
there you Oh God when you first broke in
there you will like nervous and then and
then like maybe a year or so when you
find yourself putting your elbow on the
mantel that's when you know you're
comfortable there dude I got a one of
the most embarrassing things in my life
on stage happen at that club it was so
it was one of those urban nights okay do
one of the twelve embarrassing things of
my life happen my [ __ ] Club now I was
I was only about I don't know maybe a
year into comedy right I just thought
becoming a little friendly with Breuer
so now I go down there one night now we
just
hang out try to get on that sort of
thing and Brewer and Chapelle meet up
and they're gonna go around the corner
this is again years and years ago and
they're gonna smoke a joint they invite
me to what was this like ninety two
three four like ninety four or five okay
yeah so we go around the band so just to
put a perspective men in tights for no
Nutty Professor he was making and
brewers on Saturday night one of us okay
cool because we go around the bend and
I'm like just being quiet so excited to
be hanging here right and was smoking
the joint and Chappelle's telling the
famous story about his end from Eddie
Murphy being mad at David Spade for that
remember that famous for yeah where
Spade said look a falling star and
picture Eddie Murphy catch a falling
star yeah Spade just recently wrote a
blog about it's like famous everybody
knows that story it's still going on I
think he finally saw Eddie and Eddie
said hey what's up so I think it's
finally like [ __ ] twenty years yeah
and at that point it was wild cuz I'm
sitting there getting Chappelle's end of
it because he's doing Nutty Professor
with Eddie Murphy when that happened
right and then Brewers on with Spade on
Saturday Night Live so they're telling
each other's version of the phone call
and stuff and I'm like wow so then we go
back to the club and again packed urban
night as we said it was a little cold so
I've gotten there early and I put my
coat down so this is Sunday night the
all-black show yeah people don't know
what urban nitrogen yeah yeah and urban
outfitter night and this is important to
know because I put my coat down and
they're both high and Jason who runs the
club at the time goes who wants to go in
first Jim you Dave you and they don't no
no let me relax and they go put PD on
put PD on you know and I'm frickin high
I'm not even good at comedy really so
they put me on first diet right I'm
bombing I'm three minutes in Brewer and
Chappelle oh that I in laugh and I do
about five minutes to the point we you
know black people going he's corny yeah
that's corny brutal sorry I get off and
now all I want to do is go home right I
can't find my [ __ ] coat I have no
idea what my coat is my keys to my
apartment or in my coat it's totally
dark I'm doing that what you're walking
around and you swear it's under
somebody's seat and you're like can I
just can I just I just saw you bomb yeah
yeah what you want what you want and
then
as a black host then you goes what's
going on back there it's going on back
there and somebody else now white boy
can't find this coat do i boy can't -
come on and they turn the lights on and
they're all looking around once the show
go this and I'm walking around trying to
find them finally some lady in the back
I remember I put it by that little bar
in the back there the show code now go
yeah I just took my coat and they put
the lights on I went home like that
anymore they do five minutes of stand-up
and then they're on a goddamn special
sorry brother it seems it seems like
that yeah I was just saying that what I
always loved and hated about black
crowds was they're gonna have fun either
way they either havin fun because you're
killing or you're gonna they're gonna
laugh at you either way you kill oh yeah
there'll be either you tell the joke and
people laugh or you tell the joke
there's a pause somebody else says
something and then there's like the big
laugh dude I remember one time [ __ ]
eating it in front of all black crowd
and uh there's this comedy club called
mixed nuts and now it's called the
comedy union out here in California so
uh out here in LA and I'm doing I go up
there do it and just from like from the
get-go I am just bombing yeah yeah
thirty seconds then I got dry mouth and
I am just and then I'm just plowing
through my act and nobody is saying
anything there's not a sound in the room
it's just the sound of my dry lips as
I'm [ __ ] doing these jokes and
finally two and a half excruciating
minutes of dead silence that this big
girl in the back just just commish [ __ ]
just looks at her friend and just goes
ain't laugh yet and the whole place just
goes everybody and then they just
started laughing at me and I didn't know
how to address it and I stayed in my act
and just he didn't the bubble like I was
doing my show at some other comedy club
where people were listening to it and it
was [ __ ] I'm getting embarrassed now
that you're the [ __ ] humiliation of
that to stay in your act is the worst
part about it - it's like you're just
trying to hide
this bubble of words that don't exist
man you know no you have to you have to
address it like it's weird like a white
crowd will almost get uncomfortable with
you but either way you have to break the
detention but getting back to the Boston
Common Club dude I had such horrific
sets there when I first started you know
when you first came to town like the
Steinberg and frost would [ __ ] test
you and they put you on after red Johnny
in the round yeah who murdered they were
this comedy team and I remember they
would end this set doing their version
of that song it take it takes two it
takes two to make a thing go right same
insane and they would be flicking the
[ __ ] lights on and off on and off and
dude you literally felt like dude I have
I don't have a joke in my act and they
would just throw you know that's it
show's over after that the show is over
everybody go home after like I ever saw
new guy I ever saw go down and [ __ ]
not only kill but [ __ ] level after it
was Dane Cook Dane Cook I believe had
the energy oh yeah dude he went up there
and that's the funny thing about all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was said about that
guy like they don't understand like the
level that that guy murdered I'll never
understand that right dude he went up
there and just [ __ ] like he he
treated them like that he was as a they
were like as opener he just took it to
an entirely different level and I
remember steinberg years later was
talking about him and Jason ran the room
back then and he said to me he just said
yeah man he goes I couldn't bury the kid
I couldn't bury him and I remember
thinking like yeah I knew you guys used
to do that used to when guys came down
it was the exact opposite of any other
club whether it be like oh he's a new
guy put up early put him up after the
[ __ ] you know okay act when you went
to the Boston Comedy Club they mean they
threw you right into the fire and they
right into the deep end and I think that
that's why I wanted I kept going back
there
do I still walk by that Club and during
the day if I saw it I got sick to my
stomach oh my god okay that [ __ ] fly
it dude it literally had my heart
sometimes I don't even recognize it
during the day I'd be halfway passed and
go oh [ __ ] there it is just because it's
such a night thing a dark night Bing and
but the thing about it too is uh you
know the idea that you had to go through
there and do that I like sometimes
they'll be on the road now and like
these features go I'm deciding if I
should move to LA or New York and dah
dah dah
talking about comedy and like the one
question that you gotta ask yourself is
do you love it you gotta love it so much
yeah that like you but we were blind to
that man it was no big deal you walk
home after getting beaten and battered
there and yeah tells me is quitting
never even like I never even thought
about quitting I would just immediately
be thinking about after I was getting
past I would try to think of like like
how I could do better the next time I
just remember the worst part was just
when you went to bed and just you just
laying in your [ __ ] I had to I had to
walk through bedroom railroad apartment
back then remember that [ __ ] up on 97th
Street yeah yeah and I would [ __ ]
just be laying there in the bed just
like with the humiliation of the set
just going through my [ __ ] head and
everything and like like it would take
you all the way into like maybe 2:00 in
the afternoon or the next day to finally
get your feet and for me anyways get my
feet back underneath me and then I gave
a spot at the strip and it go well oh
yeah yeah I thank God I'm still funny
I'm still funny but like I thought that
there was a lot of guys that went down
to the Boston Comedy Club and got their
heads handed to him and then they went
back up to those uptown clubs meaning
like the state of New York and the strip
yeah I just stayed there and I think
that that hurt him as comedians because
I mean who's gonna doing the Boston
comedy club exclusively would also hurt
you because then you become a hell room
comic yeah you needed that balance of
both where you go to the comic strip
you're like oh this this feels like this
what must be what it's like when you
make it
that's cardio when you work in Alec the
comic strips cardio the Muslim comedy
clubs squats yeah dead weights what do
they call those things kettlebells yeah
all that nasty stuff man exactly I was
the biggest difference and you go uptown
sometimes and then you'd be like oh this
is this is easy peasy I mean every this
is so easy but then you start to look
sometimes when I go uptown late to the
strip I'd sit in the back and I'd be
like I think it's the same white guy
just changing outfits like no they had
that they had that bet yeah rest his
soul you on first time I came down to
the comic strip and I Ellucian whole
legend in the New York comedy scene and
stand-up in general and I remember
calling there and just being like hey
Lucia I just want introduce myself
Marama comedian from boston he just nods
his head he just one I already have
enough white guys and there were so many
white guys that got offended by that go
dude so [ __ ] up if you see that about
a black guy a little bit like laughing
like it was the same thing it's just
like dude I know what this guy's saying
yeah don't be another guy coming in here
talking about the same [ __ ] I just took
that immediately it's like if you don't
have a unique voice I'm not gonna get
you on stage cuz I already have enough
for you well that's exactly it because I
would go down anywhere even at a comedy
cell for example and I would have like
my clever joke about something that
happened in the news and then I'd be
like well I'm wasting my time because
Geraldo and a towel are doing this [ __ ]
way better than I ever cried and they're
way more invested in it so I'm just
gonna talk about my life you know and
then and then I took one lesson where I
was gonna lose my accent I had the damn
car wine [ __ ] in my mouth the [ __ ]
oh yeah I'm like what the [ __ ] am i
doing just be who you are it's all this
[ __ ] that's separating you from every
other white guy some yes no not your
vessel I'm sorry man every guy in Canada
is like I mean who's the one who does
this I love that it does that's the only
it's the most physical thing I've ever
seen a comedian comic do the [ __ ]
murders yeah so funny man like - Jeremy
is something anyway Jeremy arts yeah Jay
yeah he does his nose that's like the
most physical thing is that guy when you
got a guy's gotta go see when that guy
gets on a [ __ ] roll he almost only
keeps going what a piece of [ __ ] that do
once the crowd buys in like I is one of
the hardest comics I've ever had to
follow him Greer Barnes I'll forget it
yeah what I even when I go back to the
city now and I play I always look ahead
to save Grizz on before me because
that's the one we like all right dude
the love a crowd has for Greer Barnes if
he's doing eight minutes forget about if
he's doing like a 15 minutes spot like I
always felt like when I went onstage
after him I literally felt the
disappointment like they were like oh
you know another black comic another
guy's gonna do all this cool beatbox and
characters and all this crazy [ __ ] and I
was just gonna come up there Beck yeah
you know
with Bill Clinton like knowing Ghana no
one gave a [ __ ] he literally felt like
the the I'm doing a few guys I ever just
felt like this just disappointment was
it was and I always thought it was so
genuine to where it's like obviously if
you go on after like some you know some
soap star or some [ __ ] like that that's
a different thing he's just like that
guy from day one he's another guy man I
can't figure out why that guy doesn't
well he's got that bit too for example
where he scuba diving and and he's
underwater uh-huh and the majority tab
it is complete silence he doesn't say
anything for like three minutes he's
making the noises of the bubbles and
he's in the acting this [ __ ] out and his
[ __ ] murder helling now I'm old
school I think you're a little like this
too when there's no laughs tickle I get
all bugged out I'm like it's gone okay I
mean I yeah I come when I come at it and
like when I saw you do like I said the
one we were having a catch that made me
you know again it's Brewer does that to
Chappelle take your time don't worry if
there's no laughter they're gonna come
in big at the end but you know like like
Chappelle sometimes we'll have these
two-minute bits we're not supposed to be
laughing yeah and then the end is gonna
make you die laughing but I'd be too
worried in the two minutes I'm like oh
it's better having a big ending it was
[ __ ] up though is what I first started
out I took a comedy class this guy
Vinnie favorito who's now and he works
in Vegas and I never forget he said
something in that class he was talking
about people like you know talking about
silence and people being afraid of it
and he was saying you know it's weird
you swatch a comic up there and they
[ __ ] going like 90 miles an hour and
it's not going well and he goes and all
of a sudden they go and they tell a
street joke then they just be like I two
guys walk into a bar right there's a
whole stunt of it and he goes
immediately the crowd shuts the [ __ ] up
and they listen he goes they're gonna
listen it was like a story so like
usually like a street joke when somebody
tells you a Street joke you're gonna sit
there for 45 seconds waiting for the
punchline yeah true what you do if the
guy tells the story the right way it's
gonna happen so I remember for whatever
reason that stayed with me but it took
me I think like 19 years to be able to
apply that yeah to be able to go into
areas where I just think New York and
Boston comedy scenes are similar where
it was like you
get on stage once you get your foot on
their neck you don't take it off for the
rest of the set and you like just beat
the [ __ ] out of him every [ __ ] eight
seconds like that was what you were
trying to do and there was right even I
was in Boston I would say like Tony V
and Kenny Rogers and were the only guys
that I saw that had more of like a
relaxed style and could still murder and
then you can come up there and come back
and right
I heard you dynamics it does Dan like
but when you say in how it took you a
long time to really apply it like on my
first special I have a bit long story
short where at the end of it I say
something about being a cobra and a
basket you know when someone plays the
flute so I pretend I'm a cobra in the
basket right and the bid is the flutes
playing and I get excited and eventually
I pop out and the thing about it is I
love it and it's funny but if I'm not
doing it just right I'm scratched down
and when I'm scratched down I can tell
but you wanna pop pop oh they're not
gonna laugh I'm gonna be popping up like
an [ __ ] or complete silence I
literally pop up and go in today as I'm
popping up I go I flew the other day on
Southwest like I'm already into the next
bit yeah I'm done doing the [ __ ] dude
I always I Dangerfield's the last time
Rodney went on stage I was on the show
he was on it was incredible man are you
serious I came in was a Saturday night I
mean he was he died like about a month
after that and Tony who runs the place
it was packed because it's
bridge-and-tunnel Saturday night Mike
Britt is how emceeing and he goes like
that
Rick's a beast beast so boy so funny and
Tony goes listen
Rodney's in the crowd a lot of people
don't know what he's sitting with his
wife right up front in his robe and he's
gonna come on after you Pete and you
know he liked it he didn't even really
was very old you know sometimes I'm
gonna be much of anything so I'm gonna
do 15 minutes in front of Rodney the
guys like gonna die any day I try to do
every joke I ever written in 15 minutes
like he might pop up shake my hand and
go and make a few phone calls for you
think I didn't even know he was in doors
Billy and I'm rattling off all night
right so I get off I stand off to the
side and Mike Britt introduces Rodney
place goes crazy okay Rodney gets up
he's walking so slow it's it's like four
here at a wall and it takes him like 20
min that 55 solid minutes with his wife
helping him the people even stop
clapping so I started clapping so they
keep the clap I mean keep the clap going
right he grabs the mic and imperfect
Rodney voice if you close your eyes it's
not that he grabs the mic about Mike
Brady goes how about another round of
applause for the maullion huh my bridge
bones crack it up - and he puts his arm
around Mike Brady does about a minute
and a half some joke it was very funny
and worked and then he and then he
shuffled off and then he passed away in
about a month
Wow yeah and I didn't meet him or shake
his hand or anything cuz he was back in
the crowd and I had to get back down to
the cellar oh yeah well the thing about
danger feels that when we came to New
York that Club was like it was in a bad
place where it was just like they had
comics that have been working there
since the [ __ ] place had open and if
they and it just I went in there one
night to turn and that was one of those
nights where I felt like quitting comedy
i watch this come like I say this comics
name but I saw this guy on stage and it
was the most bleakest darkest like the
negativity that was hanging in the
[ __ ] air and then what happened was
Jim Norton yes
you just said his name yes yes oh my god
do it cool like I I watched three
minutes that guy set and if I if there
was a gun in the room I would have had
in my mouth I would have shot him first
just out of just humanity yeah how
[ __ ] bleak this guy was so yeah
that's the kind of guy you want to play
in a movie to win your Oscar an
independent film fine actor what are you
going home to what are you doing when
you get home and I was sitting in there
and like dude I'm I'm not lying I love
Dangerfield's but the reverb on that mic
was [ __ ] up for like seven years
straight nobody adjusted it you know you
know what was the worst is we did like a
higher energy bit and there was nobody
in there that [ __ ] echo you know
which sounds great on like a Dean Martin
album like fills out his voice but they
[ __ ] doing like singing I'm doing
jokes it eating your balls but Norton
was the guy that first started doing it
yes you guys got a goat here you get to
do a half-hour $45 Norton
single-handedly I think saved that place
because he got us all to go there
everybody was given him [ __ ] I remember
Patrice rest his soul goes
because way coming from Norton egos
Dangerfield and he goes yeah he goes I
yeah he goes because who'd you go on
after Ruth Buzzi that everybody's dying
laughing and Norton defended it though
he's gonna dude you got to go up there
so I was living on the Upper East Side
like you and you and I started doing it
and then I remember Sherrod came in and
then there was this great thing it just
all of a sudden just [ __ ] turned
around yes all those those older guys
took off and left and but what was weird
was that you know Anna's cools the decor
remained the exact same like if you're
into like [ __ ] from back in the day you
got to go to Dangerfield to me oh really
looks like you think you feel like
Johnny Carson is gonna come walking in
when he still had like jet-black hair a
brown hair and [ __ ] like when when you
sitting there with those little [ __ ]
lampshades yeah everybody writes their
initials on the lampshades and it's
literally like a lounge in Vegas from
1970 they only have male waiters and the
weight is all still wear a red jacket
career waiters - yeah and it's a it's
just a yeah you know I mean the photos
on the wall when you first come in
because like Billy Joel did a song for
easy easy money for Rodney's movie so
there's a photo of Billy Joel was there
and yo Sinatra and all these great
panelists with Rodney but then the thing
would happen after a Wild Bill is I
would play there and then I'd be back at
the cellar and you know sometimes in
between spots everyone sits around chats
and I'm running out and ones like where
you going my god I got a Dangerfield and
he's like like it stopped tonight
because he got to the point where 75
bucks I live around the corner and I'd
be like how can I not pop in and just
get a quick 75 telleth me see mummies I
[ __ ] love that place sometimes other
times it would just learn it's the only
place I had a breakdown where I was like
the only time I was ever looking at the
crowd like what did you just call me if
the [ __ ] heat
why are you even here dude I saw so I've
seen some of the but one of the [ __ ]
most bizarre heckles I ever got and one
of the best heckles I ever saw I saw in
that room alright the one that happened
to me right I'm [ __ ] standing on
stage and this is this group I told this
one time I think I'm special or it was
an extra something it was like four
white dudes in the corner dude and you
could feel the [ __ ] anger coming off
these guys
you could feel the [ __ ] awful dad's
that beat him with belt buckles and [ __ ]
I'd like I've never felt an energy like
that in my life so I go on stage and
they're so [ __ ] angry and they're a
little loud being drunk
that they're intimidating the entire
crowd so I'm standing on stage bombing
and I know I'm bombing because those
[ __ ] guys they're energy and
everything in me is saying don't say
anything don't say anything just [ __ ]
get through the [ __ ] and then finally I
was just bombing so bad I had to say
something I was just saying like hey
what are you guys talking about over
there they like what I said yeah what
are you guys talking about over there
and the guy yells out he goes anything
redden on stage is a [ __ ] that's what
he said I don't know what the [ __ ] that
means like it was just so [ __ ] like
childish and I just but but it was
hilarious and I'm sitting there going
like I went right back into my act and
I'm sitting there part of me is lat I'm
furious the other part of me is laugh of
my ass off because I can't wait to go
down the cellar exactly tell the story
dude that's like saying anybody's
sitting over there has girl germs or
cooties like something in the second
grade but it was still [ __ ] hilarious
and I just just eaten my balls and they
did nothing about it
I forget what so ever will and I just
sat there eating my balls and got
offstage and I had to walk by the
[ __ ] table it just I don't know that
they had that one and then there was the
guy but it makes you better man somehow
those make you better man it makes you
know my mind that in a hell room but
there was always that thing weird like
when if they with you're actually in a
comedy club and they're not policing it
at all you're just like all you give a
[ __ ] is that these people are eating and
drinking yeah and if they yell at me or
throw [ __ ] at me you don't give a [ __ ]
as long as they pay the check in the end
but the other time I don't know how to
do this joke because I don't say the
guy's name because I'm saying a name but
I tell the Dangerfield Joker story but
go ahead all right so this actor slash
comedian goes on stage five all right
people in a figure doesn't like I say
his name out of respect so he [ __ ]
he's one of the funniest comics I know
I'm gonna say Frank Santorelli one of
the funniest guys ever Oh with the
cigarette and he does a cigarette oh
yeah yeah okay [ __ ] hilarious my
favorites of all time so he's on stage
and it's just this [ __ ] one of those
summertime crowds where they just
[ __ ] sitting there and while those
things like why the [ __ ] did you people
come out here exactly
they're sitting there and he goes up on
stage and he's on the soprano see I'm
plays the bartender or anything so he
goes on stage and they're just not
having it they're not listening they're
not laughing and his [ __ ] is really it's
like Greer Barnes were like he'll go
into a bit and it's like this ten-minute
high-level concept thing and then not
buying it so finally you know he's like
10 years older than me so he's trying to
reach out to this crowd because it's a
young crowd he goes hey man he goes you
guys like The Sopranos how do you guys
like The Sopranos he goes I play
so-and-so I play the bartender
every week Tony Soprano beats the [ __ ]
out of me this guy in the back without
missing a beat goes he should have
killed you Frank ever heard it I was
like oh my god that's [ __ ] hilarious
so and I wanted to laugh my balls off
but I had to go on next so I'm literally
watching the beat down then I'm gonna
take right it was like when your mother
would line you all up and you know to
beat you or whatever and you're like
waiting like okay that's this is good
maybe she'll get tired by the time she
gets to me or I shall get a phone call
something yeah so he walked offstage I'm
gonna be walked by me it's still classic
Frank funny as hell didn't say anything
he just walks by me he just doesn't look
at me just goes wow he said it twice
that's all you could do it that place
sometimes I mean Carrie Carabas used to
be on stage there at night we're doing
prom shows I used to do proms right
there oh no I just I mean that's
literally just good if you could just go
up there and stay up there for 10
minutes you get your 50 bucks or
whatever it was it was it was not about
comedy wasn't about anything are you
have a better chance going to Port
Authority and just with the mr.
microphone you get more laughs she would
yell from the stage cuz I'd be last
she'd be second unless she yelled from
the stage Cory Ali I got five four
minutes five more minutes how [ __ ]
jealous I yeah man that she's bragging
that she doesn't have to be in front of
them minutes completely then get her and
the club and the club would latch on to
the weirdest characters to be there like
comic like the comic of you know how
like you know certain kind of comics
like it tells known for the Comedy
Cellar
right yeah the 12 o'clock spot yeah yeah
so like I remember Dangerfield's went
through a phase with Steve Marshall was
hosting all the shows and he was they
got he's not there to behave
yeah
slogan so he would dude it's so weird he
would do its last bit every show he'd
have a dozen roses and he would slam
each rose against the piano as he had a
comment about women like and then you
blah blah blah and then at the end you
know the show would end and then when
everyone left he'd have to go back in
and pick up his roses like the club
wouldn't even do it for and then and
then like I remember in between shows
some time because it was a Korean deli
word get the roses you know they're like
stevia next so until it's running late
he go I don't even have my roses yet
anybody get back they don't hurry up I
go get your roses so we'd have to run
Delia's [ __ ] rose not to mention a
few paycheck and flowers man right yeah
dude are you going with that dude that's
what it doesn't charge suit I'm if I
used to work in a dental office I worked
at a dental office with my dad when I
started out and we used to have like we
were really drilling into somebody's -
that was gross man [ __ ] we'd be flying
out of the mouth so you basically had
this plastic it looked like a welder's
mask but it was all plastic yeah
so all the spittle that would hit your
face is hitting the tail shows [ __ ]
disgusting jump so I got the idea one
night that I was gonna put it on because
I was so young I was gonna put it on on
stage or whatever and I was gonna this
is gonna be my closing head so for like
like maybe two and a half months of my
stand-up career I had this little duffel
bag and I would be bringing this stupid
mask onstage and the funniest thing was
I didn't even have a joke I would just
put it on and I would just say like you
know my job during day you know you know
it's like working there whose job stinks
so bad I gotta wear this and I would put
it on and they sort of chuckle and they
were like and and where does this go and
I would just have the thing on and with
the screen in front of me like muffling
my voice I'd be like
and finally one day I figured it out I
was I was talking to this comic Todd
Parker yeah and God we come a long way
yeah and I said to him oh yeah I
actually thought that that was funny so
I talked to him I said you know I'm not
gonna do that massive thing anymore I
remember he was sitting at the kowloon
whose arms crossed looking forward not
looking at me okay yeah I'm not gonna do
that mask thing anymore and I was just
like it he just goes oh yeah
at the stage I guess yeah I just feel
like I'm just saying like I'm so not
funny I literally need to bring [ __ ] on
stage to make myself funny and he just
sort of looked at me he goes yeah yeah
you figure that out and I remember my
heart sinking going like oh my god every
comic was thinking that and I didn't
even know the whole he's a plot comic
and all that [ __ ] that you know those
guys go through they I don't give a [ __ ]
if you use process is funny I don't give
a [ __ ] ya know that's a different thing
but I mean if you're a prop guy your
prop guy you just got roses I mean
that's it it's like you got I mean you
got to go all in
yeah either got a bunch of props that's
it or absolutely nothing Vinnie favorito
would have shut down the masks hey I got
the actually I finally got the website
for Pete's special streaming on Showtime
go to SH ou comm and click on comedy and
it's gonna be on there but uh oh yeah
dummy but I could sit there and
literally tell we haven't got to the New
York Comedy Club all my sweat day you
know we're gonna discourage people from
becoming stand-up because this is just
gonna because the hell cakes are the
funniest ones
well this is although before the social
media was what it was we're like now
instead of like I'm often swept for
stage time at day and New York Comedy
Club now you know you get yourself a
nice little five minutes you get it on
the right website or something I mean
you get it out there and on the internet
and then you could start the feature
that's the other thing too with features
now it's like I mean you probably bring
your own guys but when I'm on the road
and these features are on the road it's
like this it's like the emcees really
into comedy the features like had it and
his last bits always his t-shirt sale
and then he's like you mind if I sell
and if I say well I'd rather you didn't
stand next to me and sell it's not a
flea market you know what I mean
then he won't talk to me the whole
weekend that's what happened the last
time the guy won't talk to you and he's
like you know they don't pay me enough
to feature and it's like I nobody gave a
[ __ ] about me where they never paid
enough money to feature when I featured
I had a day job
I mean Brewer would tell me how Phil
tagged my man Phil tag that yeah he had
a travel with a coffee machine in his
car and a waffle brew he told me about
one time as I can work for Phil but it's
like Brewer
that of his call when he started I
worked front desk at a hotel forever I
remember I worked I don't want to be the
guy who's all bitter on the new guys cuz
there's a bunch of guys there's a lot of
great guys right but it's just a
different thing as far it is I remember
I don't have to do a lot of that anymore
I'm never light being and working in
Baltimore and I was working with a
feature act and he was upset that he
didn't get a half-hour special and I
just remember thinking like do when I I
started just this was like 10 12 years
ago so I was only like 10 years in I'm
thinking too when I started like the
half hour specials they gave to like
seasoned headliners and they picked from
an hour of you know I'm not saying that
wasn't some week specials but it's like
you had to be a headline yeah and you
had to pick from an hour's [ __ ] it's
like you're a feature act it's oh you're
gonna go do your whole [ __ ] act you
can do everything yeah it's like they're
almost doing you a favor and they don't
see that way thank God thank God dude if
I did any specials my [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] 90s oh yeah dude I got the VHS
tapes I remember I found on one time I
was watching with my wife dude i sat
there I had my hand over my mouth I
couldn't [ __ ] I knew I was bad dude I
couldn't believe how [ __ ] bad I was
how fast I was going dude
forget about the clothes and the big
[ __ ] red afro forget about all of
that [ __ ] dude I was [ __ ] horrible
and that's the one thing that amazes me
is these kids like they get from day one
they're putting this [ __ ] up on the
internet but they've said it they a lot
of them are better than I was that quick
I'll give him that like you know some of
these guys young they're funnier than I
was they figured out how to write jokes
better than I did that young dude the
crowd know the crowd at this point
they're making videos of each other and
then they post them and they can buy
comments they learn what plays and what
doesn't like I really think it's helped
stand up because I think crowds in
general are so much more educated to uh
to stand-up comedy that it kind of
pushes you to you got to stay above you
got to keep your head above the water
lines yeah yeah you're gonna go under
but there's obviously a bunch of great
comics out there but like I think is
much all we oh we you're like I don't
want to say stuff about the young comics
I'm like all right we're gonna say good
stuff about him now and then
you say whatever you want to say I'm not
that's what the New York Comedy Club to
get stage time I mean [ __ ] the stuff we
went through to get on but here's the
thing no the same technology that
affords them to not have to have a day
job is also what you know guys like us
now decide one we're gonna do is special
so it's helping every yeah yeah and I do
know what you mean you almost like not
even like an [ __ ] way like well I had
to do this so you should have to do this
I think it helps you know no that's it
it just makes you better I mean you know
I see guys now sometimes that become
famous early and then you can see them
when you're on the show with them or
something they biting a thing emails man
they're a little worried because they
don't have like like I'll give you an
example one time I opened for old friend
you must know Billy Gardell
right oh yeah from my Kamali he's so
funny man I've done tours and he's just
such a he's really funny comedian and uh
it's in we're playing in Niagara Falls
at the Falls Roux casino I was getting
more money than I kind of ever got to
open for him I can't imagine where he
was getting and it's all these high
rollers in the crowd and stuff and he
goes up and he's doing I said to my wife
as I go this is gonna be so funny
because like when you pay this much
money to see somebody you almost don't
expect them to be good yeah because they
don't know anything about him you're
almost paying just the CETA guy right
and for the first five minutes you can
see the look in their eyes like whoa
wait wait he's got jokes I'm eight oh
he's just gonna come up here and talk
about yeah you know and it's like being
on the show and that's from years and
years of doing clubs and paying dues to
get to that point man I think you just
you got you know you could see the
relaxation in him it's not like oh don't
worry and always fun yeah he's
effortless storyteller he's just one of
those guys would be like yeah I was in
Chicago two weeks ago and you're in yeah
yeah yeah what happened what happened
well so then when I used to work front
desk at I this is funny I worked front
desk I'm sorry you got a roll no no it's
hilarious there's no way to look at the
clock without the guests thinking that
I'm just gonna make sure I don't go over
all right once we got another guy coming
in here like twelve or whatever all
right
oh yeah I got another guy coming in
looking at the car so I you know doing
the old salesman thing
coming in here at 12 so Sebastian was
telling me that you're flying
helicopters yeah I don't want to hear it
dude I don't want to hear if you're
gonna [ __ ] it like only one thing I
learned okay I'm just gonna say it's now
like the hardest thing to fly right
no this [ __ ] way harder than that but
it's more difficult than I guess
fixed-wing I've never torched it as a
regular obsessive thing but it's it's
this no it's the hardest [ __ ] is the
ground school all the [ __ ] that comics
hate having a Dede learn all the all
just all of that [ __ ] looking at charts
that airspace weather all of that stuff
it's the biggest accomplishment of my
more so than even becoming a comedian
just as far as how I'm wired how
difficult I thought it was gonna be
I just just kept going there and it was
fun and but I've learned with anything
whenever you do something like move to
LA or fly at helicopters like there's
just like a certain or just put your
[ __ ] out on the internet there's always
that new level of tough skin you're
gonna have to get yeah like you go to LA
every oh my god they're so plastic
everybody's so phony you lose your edge
the comics stink and you're gonna have
Botox in your faces you got to like
block all of that out right and then
like with aviation I've learned is just
if the person you talk to also doesn't
fly they're just gonna tell you you're
gonna die immediately just gotta let go
you just got a bit I flew yesterday dude
the first time I flew in like a little
over a month and I can't even tell you
how much [ __ ] fun it was I flew from
Long Beach I went up the 710 North and I
went straight up it goes right to
Pasadena and right to the left you see
the Rose Bowl I'll show you video I did
a loop around the Rose Bowl now are you
are you so low at this point
no I'm doing it so low tomorrow like I
just like I'm really cautious cuz like I
was going like all right let me do this
flight once with the instructor I go and
then I'll come back Thursday I'll do it
once with you and then I'll do it by the
time I was coming flying back yeah I was
like dude I can do this one by myself
any cuz I yeah it was you're totally
ready you got your head on a swivel
you're doing the radio colors you got
the whole you got it down so but why
copter over plane
why not plane I mean copter so like yeah
drive a Jeep Wrangler
Franklin right there that's Compton yeah
yeah you didn't [ __ ] that grow up
watching uh
magnum p.i yeah I wanna be the guy in a
helicopter that was kidding me yeah OTC
Rick and Magnum dude I love that you
think it Jeep is cool that's so our
generation like I don't know kids think
I [ __ ] yes I have such a great Boston
stories reminds me of you were Robert
sometimes with the accent my brother
lived in Boston for a little while and
my wife and I Jack you were visiting him
I had my Jeep Wrangler as New York
plates and even says Manhattan on it
because a Manhattan dealership had we
won the World Series yet yeah yeah oh
yeah that's not too bad no it's not too
long ago and I'm at a red light and
nobody's banging oh right like to turn
right and I'm just saying to my wife and
summertime I get the top down on my
typical [ __ ] Boston I mean just bang
the right what are you doing here right
right next to me is a parking lot so I'm
like screw these people I'm just gonna
my head and I'm just gonna cut through
the parking lot so I just turned the
wheel and I'm gonna cut through the
parking lot now what I didn't see is it
was a curb right next to me so I floor
and I turned the wheel and the Jeep hits
the curb and like the dog almost flies
out of Jeep my wife had bangs everything
and I'm like holy [ __ ] you know and
we're just trying to regroup and in
perfect Boston accent right behind me
you hear some guy yell out yeah you go
New York you hear oh you you go oh my
god [ __ ] embarrass to you right now
yeah just gives you I'm a hero
I don't wait for the light oh god hey I
gotta ask you as far as uh as far as uh
you know your sports affiliation as I
remember you're one of those weird Jets
Yankees guys yes because it's always
Jets Mets Yankees Giants yeah
so I said yeah I took a year off with
the Yankees hat I'm in mourning
Fujita I just took a whole season yeah
Red Sox fan to unhittable
one of the one of the few unattainable
people like Steph Curry unhittable
yeah okay hate him looks like Big Papi
man it's even like Tom Brady I mean I'm
a jet fan but it's like I've seen last
year we're doing a show and someone was
talking about Russell Wilson Zeus and I
go listen Russell Wilson's great for
Seattle
Tom Brady is great for America yeah we
lost obviously I was actually my last
podcast I did I was watching the game
live and people loving it and like
hearing me flipping out and everything
but I gotta be honest with you dude
after watching that year we won 18 and
one yeah
like dude an undefeated record in this
day and age it's not like when the
[ __ ] dolphin stated no you know I
mean when you had like white cornerbacks
and [ __ ] and there's still you know
sports was five minutes after the end of
the dude so to say I could drum 30 on
Bob Cousy if he was playing today all
right what about the me that's hilarious
dude that's [ __ ] hilarious but they
like an undefeated record is a [ __ ]
albatross around your goddamn neck
people getting people already get amped
up if you're defending Super Bowl
champions or if you had a nice run they
want to [ __ ] beat you then they just
want to be the guy that knocks you off
and I remember that year we went 18 and
one like dude what we we [ __ ] up was
because you know Raymond Jeanie dropped
dime on us that we were film and [ __ ]
the signs and [ __ ] yeah and then
everybody questioned all of our titles
so then they went into this rape and
pillage mode for about three weeks and
they were like oh yeah this is what we
could have been doing to you and they
would lesson Lee started doing that [ __ ]
like you know going for two and running
up in the school and they were
embarrassing people it's the dumbest
thing we could ever do by October
everyone was like oh you're not [ __ ]
embarrassing us and dude we played like
a playoff level atmosphere I swear to
God somewhere around the cowboy game or
the cult game in mid-october for the
rest of the time of the Ravens that year
or somebody sucked and we played a
monday night football and the place was
packed and people were like with the
towel at the Terrible Towel thing going
over their head for a [ __ ] like a
game in oh man yeah and they and they
were completely out of the play maybe it
wasn't the Ravens where they're
completely out of the playoff picture so
I'm actually I don't give a [ __ ] about
the undefeated thing you want the
championship but of course
well what I'm nervous about is like the
only star we got left is Brady
everybody's everybody's out yeah but
come on let's be honest I mean you guys
my next-door neighbor your next-door
neighbor could be running across
patterns for Brady next week for all we
know I mean did I did anyone know
Edelman
these little white guys just ran I don't
even know any of these guys except for
the grass I felt the same way about
Magic Johnson like if I ever played
on the Lakers at my age right now 47
year-old slow [ __ ] white dude if I
played with magic on the Showtime Lakers
at the end of the game somehow I would
have like three points and then I should
have had like 12 yeah oh yeah he'll set
you up ahead
you'll have three points here five other
times you'll be going back down going my
bad my bad magic yeah like there's
there's a few guys out there that I like
that so I got to ask as a Jets fan
how did you feel about the move with Rex
Ryan getting rid of him did you feel
like he ran the course runner because I
think that guys are really he's a really
good coach he just I feel like his big
thing is he hasn't had a quarterback
like yeah Sanchez was not as good as
people said he was but he's not as bad
as they say like I think you know I
think it should be starting up a
Bradford well I don't know man I mean
he's he's got no it's soft this throws
us off to his there's no cannon isn't I
mean now we got Fitzpatrick who's too
short I've never seen a guy's balls get
knocked down so many times it's wrong I
mean nuts but you're right I mean but
why can't Rex Ryan just come out and say
guys that's so bad to say it's like give
me a quarterback in hallway man I've
never had even now time he came into the
England beat you guys beat us in the
playoffs in New England after we [ __ ]
killed you in December when I didn't
[ __ ] count you guys came back does
that's the thing about him we meet the
bills again in the playoffs like that's
in the back of my head I'm thinking like
I who do they got out there in Buffalo
for quarterback tie rod tails yeah yeah
I look right outside there yeah you're
like what Rochester no I live in a small
town called Fredonia but 45 minutes away
from Buffalo dude I live where I went to
college I live it down the block from my
college now how do you how do you like
it out there
I it's a small town in college at town I
love it but I mean so I know you got to
go by God's a rule no no no I I played
basketball Division three there right
right and by my junior year I was named
captain and I quit and I remember to
coach bringing me in he's like you're
making a big mistake but all the guys
had played but already were gone now his
young kids and they didn't like to drink
and party on the road which I did so I
felt with these guys wait a minute you
were gonna be captain of the timwas cat
and you quit cuz your teammates wouldn't
drink and smoke with you well I didn't
smoke but yeah this is [ __ ] awesome
yeah but they wouldn't
old school but I'm like what Division
three we're not on scholarship that
dream is gone we're going to Rochester
for a weekend tournament you're not
gonna go out to the bar and meet
Rochester girls what are you it so my
guy what are you gonna play in the
turkey someday it's done Division three
on center was six four get the memo yes
so my coach told me I regret it you know
and I was like no I'm quitting and I do
I do it I would literally have dreams as
years later that I was a senior dropping
40 points it was dumb I should I was in
such a rush to party and I realized the
party's never Rove especially when you
graduate you moved to the city so cut to
22 what two years later by chain of
events my wife's from this area I have a
daughter now she doesn't wanna be in the
city we moved back to and it's the
nicest town around so we moved back in
there living in a big old Victorian home
right around the corner from my college
it's Christmas morning and I'm shoveling
my driveway at 7 a.m. and a car pulls up
at the end of the driveway and I hear a
voice go Pete Cory Ellie and the window
comes down and it's my coach now my
coach and he goes I heard you moved to
town we're gonna get coffee soon and
then he looks down he goes Merry
Christmas
Jackie Jackie it was the coach we're
gonna get coffee Oh cuz he never really
forgave you for that no he never forgave
me he's now they're just the school's of
AD or whatever you know and he's like oh
we want you to come to a show for the
for the kids and will you talk to the
team I go I'll talk to the team about
not quitting because they everyone quits
they wanted to get a scholarship they
didn't get a scholarship so then they go
screw this and they quit and I'm gonna
tell him but it was just funny man you
know but I'm on the road a lot so it's
not like you know that's what no no not
it look believe me do it this way to you
if I was in a if I was in a you know if
I wasn't in this business I wouldn't
live out here but I I actually do love
it out here I do - I like that was here
for a year my wife and I like that was
getting into boogie boardin in Manhattan
Beach if you embrace it exactly about it
is you know we're so East Coast it you
know eventually you're going back like I
don't know maybe I will maybe I won't
but it's just like so you ain't go like
what I don't know I don't know it
depends what this drought to me might
have to go back but the the first time I
live in LA in the late 90s I was like I
hated it because I wanted to be in New
York and then the next time I came back
out in like 2007 or eight when I came
out here I was like you know what I'm
gonna embrace it this time I'm gonna
[ __ ] hike it I'm gonna yeah and go
out to the beach and why I'm not gonna
pitch him to [ __ ] pasty but like you
know I gotta the helicopter thing out
here I played pick-up hockey I've had
actually took the time to build a
[ __ ] life out here Shroff because the
first time I was you know sitting in you
know one-bedroom apartment sparsely
furnished I just was not yeah I was not
committed to the [ __ ] that was back when
they had all the pilot season and all
that that was a big [ __ ] jerk-off
every year you come out here and try to
get on some but um but anyways to wrap
it up here dude just no Christmas out
here that's the only thing that pisses
for you all I mean way that I saw one
treat I fathered me the year I lived
here I'm like is everybody Jewish
dislike no nothing I mean we got the
carols going back east man no man well
look you can now you can skate you can
go skating I don't know how they do this
especially with a [ __ ] drought like
right outside the Staples Center you can
somehow go skating and out in Santa
Monica they have something like every
year but if you know where to go there's
a place in Pasadena like this just dude
it's it's like the sickest [ __ ]
houses you've ever seen where they
actually have like no they really get
into it dude it looks like Vanderbilt
rockefeller money and they have these
all these giant [ __ ] trees that look
like giant giant Christmas trees and
they're all [ __ ] rich so they just
pay somebody to come in with like a
crane and they light up all of these
call it Christmas tree row or something
that's [ __ ] insane it's like
Illuminati money and they allow you to
go down this street once a year yeah and
then you got a [ __ ] beat it but
before we get out of here dude you're
one of my favorites of all time you're
one of the great storytellers as people
could tell and this is a guy like don't
sleep on Pete Corey Ali's new special
let me tell you it's streaming right now
on show com sh o comm just click on
comedy his he does an awesome podcast
with Sebastian who's one of the best
comics out there who actually he must
have told you he lived right down the
hall for me when I lived in that shitty
[ __ ] one-bedroom apartment you know
and through before I have a [ __ ]
before he ever did comedy I ran into him
he's just a Chicago guy and he goes ah
he's like you know you know Sebastian
when he doesn't know you he comes out he
goes hey you're uh you're comedian right
yeah I go yeah you know I'm all excited
something and he just kind of nods me
into shutting up like I sort of nodded
and I just sort of got quiet again yeah
because yeah I seen their senior yeah
I've been thinking thinking about doing
it you know how do you uh how do you go
about that so I gave him you know some
advice and I kind of got to know him a
little bit yeah and then I moved away
like right after that and like four or
five years later I'm coming out here
same type of jerk-off thing coming out
here for a half-hour special I got to
pay my own way out here I show up I go
on first at the Comedy Store there's
five people in the [ __ ] crowd I eat
my balls I'm a dressed on how there's
only five people there nobody's laughing
and then the guy was set up the [ __ ]
showcase gave me [ __ ] because there was
nobody there because we know there's
nobody here
we listen to the material here I always
wanted to go back in time be like hey
[ __ ]
don't have a [ __ ] showcase with no
people in the [ __ ] crowd how about
that yeah how about I just paid all this
[ __ ] money like I'm still mad about
that man so anyways yeah so I went out
there like [ __ ] mm like three or four
and this was like the late 90s when I
saw him and I see this guy on stage and
I'm like I've recognized him but I can't
figure out where and I go what's this
guy's name it goes Sebastian it's like
who I know once Sebastian my whole
[ __ ] life
yeah and I'm looking going into I go
that's it [ __ ] guy for me he's doing
stand-up and that guy he did the hardest
thing ever he started Ground Zero in
lausanne heard of it's practically
impossible it became a monster [ __ ]
comic who has an unbelievable work ethic
and rights and like in you know so
anyways Pete does a show with them on
riot cast is called the Pete and
Sebastien show on the right cast network
which is WWE cast calm your Twitter is
Mike or elec orr EA le your website is
WWE
so you're one of my favorites and if
you've seen this guy go see him on the
road go see his comedy special
so great to run into you man and in la
you're in Rochester never happens
anymore Buffalo area I got to tell you
one quick last thing I was someone said
to me house house stuff change for you
and two days ago my wife and I rake in
my leaves in the front lawn and a dude
comes by and look really good did a nice
job but I swear the guy who looks at me
and he's like you got a card oh god I
don't know I live here oh no cause you
deuce it looks so fantastic special
comes out guys asking me if all right
it's guy danlily
see that's why you gotta watch it
special Thank You Man it's been so great
hanging what you dude [ __ ] I imagine
you next time I'll see you I will be
it's some sort of comedy festival and we
got a we got to do it up the way we used
to either that I come into town you're
gonna give me a ride in that copter bro
oh if you want to I will I'll take my
chances man we have as documented to
extent god forbid something [ __ ]
happens he said he wasn't worried - all
right you guys that's that's a Thursday
afternoon just before Monday just for
Friday Monday morning podcast thank you
for listening I'll talk to you on Monday
have a good weekend you can't can't
can't can't can't can't can't can't
can't can't can't can't can't